Myanmar the long road to reforms in the
interview the president of Myanmar
same-same a warm welcome present and
sent to Berlin and to Germany a pleasure
to have you here you've been president
for three years of Myanmar what do you
think are you satisfied with the
progress your country has made in these
three years first of all let me say that
it's a pleasure to be interviewed by
Deutsche Welle during my visit to
Germany okay as you said three years
have passed since the introduction of
reforms I'm quite satisfied with how the
process of reform has taken place in
Myanmar since then the transition has
been smooth and without bloodshed that
has not been the case in other countries
which have undergone similar transitions
it must be noted that the reforms in
Myanmar took place about the same time
as the Arab Spring however unlike what
happened in many countries in the Middle
East the transition and introduction of
reforms in Myanmar have been quite
smooth I'm very encouraged and pleased
that we were able to avoid the bloodshed
and casualties we saw in the Middle East
you became president after first
elections in 20 years held in Myanmar
you it was rude by military junta till
then what made you actually embark on
this progressive reform you are
described as the architect of the
reforms in Myanmar yes Myanmar was
indeed ruled by a military government as
you know there are many ethnic groups in
the country and there has been a history
of conflict among them in order to
ensure peace and stability and to
safeguard national security the military
government maintained
power for nearly 20 years but the people
of Myanmar longed for a democratic
system of government something the
military rulers at the time were fully
aware of so as well as ensuring national
security the former military government
also laid down the foundations necessary
for democracy to flourish in the country
it approached the transition to
democracy in a systematic manner as
you're aware in 2003 the military
government laid down a seven-step
roadmap to democracy which it then
implemented there is a genuine long for
democracy among Myanmar's people and the
military government has attempted to
realize that desire so to return to your
question as we go about building a
democratic state our focus is
unlistenable want we try to instigate
change and reform based on what the
people of me and my desire real chicken
with many people in a near master defeat
that the military is running the
government twenty-five percent of the
seats in parliament are reserved the
military officers three key positions
ministries in Myanmar defense interior
and border security I had my serving
army generals when will this change
because of the military still
controlling a parliament you cannot have
a democratic change we are fully aware
that the people of Myanmar would like to
see the role of the military gradually
reduced but it's also important to
consider the special nature of the
present situation
in Myanmar we have several armed ethnic
groups at present there are 16 of them
operating they're assigning major
positions to the military reflects the
need to maintain national security as
you correctly said military
representatives make up twenty-five
percent of the Parliament the three key
ministries of Defense home and border
affairs are managed by experienced
military personnel but I must also point
out that Myanmar's development as a
democracy will be accompanied by a
reduction in military rule now that mean
Muslim to report addictions and next
year I understand the president again
you're right we will be holding
elections in 2015 but to be honest I'm
70 years of age and have served my
country in various capacities I would
like to retire I also need to consider
my health but while I do not intend to
stand again at present it's my
responsibility to ensure peace and
stability well and serve the people of
Myanmar so that rather than considering
whether I should run in the next
election is my priority at present but I
will be supporting anyone who will help
lead Myanmar to a peaceful and
prosperous future no solution one person
who would like your job is opposition
and pro-democracy leader Aung San Suchi
we should be allowed to Santa president
only know she right now there are
certain conditions restricting her from
running for the highest office as you
know her husband was a British national
a foreigner and her sons are also
British citizens fukunaga
full she herself however is a citizen of
Myanmar so at present she's prohibited
from running for the top political role
however there are also plans to amend
the current constitution but that
depends on the people and their
representatives so this constitution was
created by the military junta and to
reform this constitution you have to
have more than 75 percent of the votes
in Parliament 25% of the votes are
reserved for the military so unless the
military agrees the Constitution cannot
be changed this is article 59 which many
critics say was only designed to stop
unsound suchi staying a complete
contesting in elections because her late
husband was British and her two sons
have British nationality so she can
never actually stand for president there
was a committee recently which said it
will not change out to be 59 what are
your personal views would you like on
some smoochie to stand for president
first let me say something about
Myanmar's constitution while it was
indeed crafted during the rule of the
military government in the context of
transferring to a democratic system the
process has included people from all
walks of life it was not purely drafted
by the military some provisions
contained in the constitution can be
amended with the approval of a
parliamentary majority of two-thirds
in other cases however the Constitution
dictates that a referendum must be held
I genuinely do not want to see on some
sushi or any other citizen barred from
contesting the top leadership role in
Myanmar but at the same time we must
consider the will of the people we must
also give serious consideration to the
fundamental principle of our sovereignty
and territorial integrity and the
measures needed to safeguard them I
think I hit him now I mean if the will
of the people was to be heard in Myanmar
in 1990 on some smoochies National
League for Democracy won a landslide but
that's history now I make unsung suci in
our first overseas trip after she was
released from house arrest in Bangkok
and I put the question to her would she
be there if it wasn't for you the
President and said so my question to you
is after you go other reforms in Myanmar
irreversible my political path is simply
to move forward with the reforms and
avoid any steps backwards at present I'm
focusing on laying a solid foundation so
that reforms and Myanmar can continue I
believe that if we can lay a solid
ground work anyone who takes over as
leader of the country will proceed with
the process of reform but of course for
that to happen and to make progress we
need the understanding assistance and
encouragement of the international
community and the international
community has recognized the progress
made by
indmar in these three short years three
years is a very short time in the
history of a country President Obama has
visited your country he's coming again
at the end of this year Myanmar is the
chair of ASEAN the German president
visited you early this year but
everybody is saying even in talks with
the German Chancellor that it and help
and encouragement for made my expedition
el on the reform process containing and
improvements in human rights can you
assure the international community that
this way to go ahead Myanmar's reforms
are not only instigated by the
government they're also contingent on
the people's wishes and as I said
earlier they desire a democratic system
as members of the government it's our
duty to respond to those needs and
oversee a move in a direction that will
ensure that democracy can flourish in
our country but it must also be said
that such a successful democratic system
relies not only on the support of the
international community but also on the
media mr. that's what do you see as the
biggest challenge for your country
single moral the biggest challenge is
helping the people to understand how
democracy works now that they have a
democratic system of government they're
enjoying the freedom that that entails
at the same time they often neglect to
remember that such freedoms must
necessarily be accompanied by
accountability and responsibility like
any other place undergoing a democratic
transition we are experiencing other
challenges and obstacles to but we're
confident that we will be able to
overcome them by working together owwww
we wish you luck in your past was full
and meaningful democracy pleasanton said
it was a pleasure to talk to you thank
you very much
thank you thank you